bien souvent quand je prends la parole
je souligne souvent les spécificités de
la Guyane sur bien des situations car je
pense qu'il est utile d'apporter un
éclairage à mes collègues sur mon
territoire il est très difficile
d'entreprendre en Guyane même avec un
bon diplôme et l'expérience entre les
banques et les démarches administratives
c'est souvent le renoncement plutôt que
la boutissement d'ailleurs dernièrement
j'ai organisé une conférence des balles
le 18 avril dernier en Guyane avec pour
thème être jeune et acteur du
développement de la Guyane afin
d'écouter les doléances mais aussi les
espoirs de notre jeunesse c'est vrai que
suite à cette conférence débat suivront
des causeries parce que je crois que la
jeunesse guyanaise est très demande
alors Cynthia
excusez-moi je l'appelle Cynthia parce
que je la connais très bien alors de par
ton expérience personnelle et
associative aurais-tu des pistes à
préconiser afin d'encourager les jeunes
porteurs de projets parce qu'il y en a
mais les malheureux ils sont bloqués
parce qu'ils savent pas où aller tu
parlais de réseau tout à l'heure et je
crois que c'est important de communiquer
parce qu'il frappe à des portes et en
fait ils n'obtiennent pas de réponse et
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut il repartent
en France hexagonale tout simplement
alors qu'on a besoin de ces matières
grises chez nous on a besoin de
développer le pays et c'est triste
en tant que tel on n'a pas fait on n'a
pas fait de focus effectivement bon
généralement ce qu'on constate c'est que
les obstacles et les contraintes sont
parfois plus élevées en Guyane même si
effectivement il y a tout à fait donc
pour beaucoup de jeunes qui va d'abord
revenir en premier lieu c'est le manque
d'information en dépit du caractère
plutôt enfin ce sont des petits marchés
voilà une population certes en forte
croissance mais le réseau peut
facilement être créé en profitant en
faisant de cette petite session un atout
c'est à dire celui de la proximité et ce
qu'on constate c'est qu'effectivement
cette proximité qui pourrait être
facilement stimulée ne l'est pas et donc
du coup conduit à un manque
d'information et de visibilité donc la
question effectivement de rendre
accessible les opportunités ça c'est un
réel enjeu deuxième point c'est
effectivement aussi contre pour enfin
lutter contre le découragement et se
dire que ça va être trop compliqué c'est
donner à voir l'exemplarité je pense
qu'on pourrait encore davantage
communiquer sur les porteurs de projet
les jeunes diplômés aussi salariés qui
se lancent et parviennent effectivement
à faire aboutir en tout cas faire déjà
décoller leurs projets et vous avez
raison madame la sénatrice il y a des il
y a des jeunes talents qui ont envie de
créer leur job créent leur entreprise on
a vu enfin j'ai essayé de lister toutes
les difficultés qui s'attachent de notre
point de vue à la création d'entreprise
ou à la au développement des entreprises
d'une façon générale dans les outre-mer
mais je voudrais signaler quand même
qu'il y a certaines expériences qu'il
faut avoir en tête face à certains
organismes ou certains dispositifs qui
peuvent aider les créateurs d'entreprise
à faire ce premier pas à s'installer etc
c'est d'abord Lady qui est très présent
dans les outre-mer que nous soutenons
financièrement mais c'est 11800
bénéficiaires l'année dernière et 70
millions d'aides de micro de prêt sur
l'honneur de garantie de près qui ont
été accordées c'est vraiment leur métier
d'accompagner les premiers pas du
créateur d'entreprise il a dit ça permet
aussi de sortir de l'informel de
s'installer d'être de se mettre à son
compte